Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's always
my favorite when they show porn
cutting, with like a,
"And the lights are down."
Then they get like one
or two more like,
"Yeah," and then they stop.
I told you, dude, there was that
-
And then they go,
"And we're up and rolling.
You guys good to go?"
And he goes, "Yeah, yeah,"
and just start it back up again.
That was that, I told you there
was that series that was free.
I don't know if it's one
of those porn networks
or whatever online,
but it's people trying out
for porno and being critiqued.
The American Idol?
"You suck dick like
you don't have hands."
Yes. It's a Real World style.
They all live in the place,
so they have drama.
I need to see this.
I didn't know about this.
They sabotage ...
One girl's sabotaging the guy.
The guy's fucking her
and she's just laying there,
like kind of dead.
You're saying that a girl
sabotages a guy
that she's fucking?
Yes.
That is hilarious.
He goes, "What are you doing?"
He's whispering to her,
and they subtitle like,
"What are you doing?
You have to ... come on.
We only have five minutes."
and she goes,
"You said that I was
the shittiest lay in the house."
He's like, "Are you gonna
fucking do this right here?"
She's like, "You said I'm the
shittiest lay in the house,
so I guess I'll be the shittiest
lay in the house."
He goes, "Yeah, you're being
marked on this too."
She's like,
"I'm not going anywhere.
You ain't gonna fucking-"
Please tell me they cut Survivor
style to fucking testimonials.
Yes. Yes.
She goes,
"He once talked shit about me
and this is what he gets."
Yes, absolutely,
that's what it is.
What is the name of this show?
What is this?
Don't do this to me, bro.
Just do porn reality challenge
or something.
Porn reality?
Next Porn Star?
You get to these places on these
generic Japanese descriptions?
"Porn sexy lady competition."
"Fuck woman hair twat"
The more straightforward you go,
the better you're
going to find ...
people try to do
these nice, eloquent.
You gotta go straight for it.
"Dick in face," boom boom boom,
you're right there.
Big tits.
I've done things like
"party bus cum shots."
What does that even mean?
Sometimes they have videos
of people fucking on party buses
and they shoot cum
on the girl's face.
There you go. Easy work.
Yeah, Ali goes, and that's
how you bring up a video.
Sex factor?
Sex Factor?
That's probably it.
Yeah.
Oh dude I'm gonna be watching
so much of this.
Yep.
This is great.
It's great.
It is super jerkable.
What the [crosstalk 00:02:27].
It's a million dollar
porn competition?
Come on guys we're past ...
What's the-
But you meet 'em all at first
and then they just
have to start fucking.
Only one black guy
just like real reality shows.
Only one black dude they're
gonna make him feel like shit.
Dude this might be
the only thing that can get you
to watch
a whole porn these days
'cause you're like I've got to
see if she got to live with it.
Well I'll tell you what-
My balls got a little-
I watched at least a minute
of every episode.
I think I did it all
in one shot.
What's playing with the pros?
Playing with the pros
do they get to fuck
a seasoned porn star?
Yes. Yeah. Yes.
Dude that's they come in-
The black guys already off?
And it's xHamster.
Oh no he's in. He's in.
I'll tell you what the black guy
can't cum
in the one thing I saw.
Oh he can't cum.
Let me tell you something.
Porn is not as easy
as people think.
No at all.
I would never think.
It's a actual dude
that's on that.
You don't have to be
the main dude.
You can be a stunt dude,
you can be a stunt penis.
Yeah.
Well you just stand there
and the dude can't get it up
you got to go in and pound
'til they tell you to come out.
Is there a lady with a headset
and a clipboard going,
"You're on. Go, go. Go.
Start cock, start cock. Hard."
"Now, now, slap it in,
slap it in, get out."
You have Cheetos dust
on your fingers you're like,
"Shit all right."
[inaudible 00:03:39]
eating a small bag of Cheetos
he goes,
"He's soft again?
All right. Okay."
This son of a bitch says he's-
You have any white vinegar?
This son of a bitch say's he's
Italian can't even get it up.
He's smoking a cigarette
they go, "Don."
He goes, "All right.
All right."
Cheetos dust.
He goes-
Why does he got
the Cheetos dust?
"Someone give her the digits
real quick.
I'll be over in a second let me
fucking get the truck going.
I call my dick the truck."
Isn't this great self-
It's just weird.
But it's great because you know
it's like he's a dude trying out
and people are watching him.
And he's doing his best,
but yo okay
I've slept with
a porn star before.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right this is early on.
I don't know if she was a star.
She was a porn person.
Sure. That's hilarious.
Let's not say-
She suck dick on camera
at least.
I don't know if she's
a porn star.
She had a real rough past,
but it got us to here
and I don't know.
I'm guessing porn
might've been there.
Dicey films.
He goes, "I'll tell you this
I wouldn't use your social.
That things dusted up."
I'm telling you she literally,
she has movies.
Her name is Hazel Eyes.
Oh I know Hazel Eyes.
That's so funny.
I probably do too.
I definitely know.
Yeah light skinned chick
with real nice eyes.
Hey I met her
in Shreveport.
Louisiana.
Yep Shreveport, Louisiana.
[inaudible 00:04:59].
And what's crazy is
how do we jump
into a lightweight
little relationship.
It wasn't like a-
Because, was it the sex
was so good
and it was so amazing
to you that you're like,
"I got to keep coming back."
No she told me not to watch
any of her movies.
Okay.
I'm way past that.
I know who you are.
Like you are waitressing
right now
I'm the one that said,
"Psst ain't you Hazel Eyes?"
I said that.
That's got to be where she goes,
"Okay so you have
the chicken parm
and I'm gonna bring you ..."
And you go,
"Are you Hazel Eyes?"
And she goes, "Fuck, yes."
We went to Waffle House,
no we went to IHOP
in Bossier city
which is right across.
That's where you take 'em.
And that was the only place,
that was the only place.
And that's where you take 'em.
She goes, "Can we eat there?"
He goes,
"You eat at the International
House of Pancakes."
It was different.
She goes, "Don't make your bacon
a smile face on your pancake."
She go, "I like food
that gives me emotions."
I met another chick
that was a porn star.
We went out to Pappadeaux
in Houston.
I think she was engaged
to Wesley Pipes.
Really?
He just came up earlier today.
We were just talking
about Wesley Pipes.
I brought him up.
Yeah. I think she was engaged
to Wesley Pipes.
I thought that he had
two guns right here.
That's what we were
just talking about.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I asked if he ever gets silly
and goes like this.
It's only one.
So he does the Robo cop?
It's the only one.
You're coming with me.
She told me that.
He's like Wyatt Earp.
She told me it's only one gun.
I was like, "Okay."
"I have two guns."
He grabs his dick.
He grabs his dick
and the one,
"I have two guns one
for the each of you."
Wesley Pipes has to be
the most ridiculous porn man.
He says, I'm talking about
if I was a porn lady
I'd be like,
"Yo I don't want him."
Rocco Siffredi's pretty bad.
Yeah. 'Cause he was like,
"Oh yo baby."
He was like half European
so he's like,
"[inaudible 00:06:49]."
And he had to have put his foot
in your head in a toilet.
Oh yeah that dude.
I only see one or two of his.
And he be like,
"[inaudible 00:06:55]."
Randy West was always
my favorite
'cause he was the most like
punk rock one, two, three.
He be like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah."
He'd play the power chords.
I think I could be with a chick
who was in porn.
Yeah I could.
But not currently in porn.
No.
No, not current.
You'd have to be out
of the life.
You had to be out the life.
I can't be dating a bank robber.
It's got to be out
of the public.
of the public eye.
I mean yeah I'd be okay with it.
It'll never really out
of the ...
Everybody's only watching
classic clips.
You never really go back,
who's buying the new stuff?
I don't want to walk in like,
"I need some-"
Is there even a new
release section?
There is, but no ones
checking it out.
You only want the stuff
from a year ago.
There's a lot of people
out there
putting good product out there.
You guys just need
to know where to look.
People are watching
[Hart Brazzers 00:07:38]
he's bigger than ever.